hi i'm jean-paul of blue smoke in new
york city and these are the things you
cannot miss when you come to blue smoke
beef back ribs cult following on the
beef ribs that we rub they go into the
smoker they smoke for about five and a
half hours at 225 degrees the texture of
beef ribs they're soft and they're
cooked and they're juicy they're not
going to just fall off the bone you want
to like get in there hold on with two
hands and go at it can't go half step on
the beef rubs you got to order the whole
rack
[Music]
the brisket rub we actually use it's a
seven pepper rub when it comes out it's
all toasted so when all those peppers
toast and beef fat the bark is so
complex brisket is one of those things
that you always want to slice against
the grain then you're slicing in that
soft delicate brisket meat and that's
what gives you that kind of lip smacking
glistening sheen that's the really soft
and kind of like just melt away piece of
the meat
[Music]
the cornbread madeleines will probably
be the legacy of me at blue smoke the
cornbread batter is a special batter
that works really only in madeline molds
in the bake to order crispy on the
outside then warm and soft and delicate
on the inside they literally will come
out that oven and to your table as soon
as they're finished
barbecue chips with blue cheese and
bacon dip gives you that wow moment
because that blue cheese dip is generous
on the blue cheese bacon and chive and
all that works together great with the
chip
[Music]
alabama white wings this is by far one
of the most talked about wings in the
city the wings are first grind then
they're rubbed then they're smoked
that's a whole lot of work to go in for
a wing they really are one of those more
like perfect things we do alabama white
sauce the ingredients that really make
it pop are white soy sauce and white
miso that mixed with the richness of the
mayonnaise and sharpness of the vinegar
that's really hitting on all of those
pallet sensories
[Music]
mac and cheese the pasta is cooked fresh
that's how you get the noodles that
aren't mushy or over watery and then to
order it is mixed with the cheese sauce
cheese sauce is no flour no roux just
straight cheese and aromatics this is
the creamy
rich style mac and cheese you can add
chopped barbecue jalapenos and i like it
with the chopped barbecue and jalapenos
because you're here why not just go all
in right
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you